Consider yourself invited to grab a membership at
join Pacman dot com. Our primary revenue source.
Quick, easy and you get the daily bonus
show. Join Pacman. Dot com is the place.
This morning I was browsing the David Pakman
show sub Reddit, which now has a subscriber base
of more than 24000 of our viewers and listeners at
David Pakman dot com slash Reddit. Few interesting
posts. One is an article from the Associated
Press pointing out that Donald Trump's Supreme
Court nominee, Amy CONI Barrett, was a trustee
at a private school with anti-gay policies.
And one of one of the comments here is spot on,
which is imagine if instead of being a trustee
at a Christian school with anti-gay policies, if
Amy CONI Barrett was a trustee at a Muslim school
with exactly the same policies, what would
conservatives be saying right now? I think
you all know exactly what they would be saying. It
would be a dramatically different situation. Also,
an interesting post on the sub Reddit linking
to a poll about the intellectual dark web
and the political leanings
of the intellectual dark web.
And the discussion was initially about, oh, the
intellectual dark web is mostly voting for Trump.
And then the poll results reversed and it looked
like the intellectual dark web sub Reddit was
mostly voting for Joe Biden. But then it wasn't
clear if this was a fair poll or not a fair poll.
I actually think we've talked about
the intellectual dark web a lot.
I don't even really think the most interesting
area of looking at the intellectual, intellectual,
dark web relates to do the people that choose to
respond to a poll plan to vote for Donald Trump
or Joe Biden, particularly because the polls can
go so much one way or the other? For me, the most
interesting thing about the intellectual dark web
is actually examining the argument that the dark
Web idea comes from this notion that you can't get
the views of the members of the intellectual dark
web unless you look in really bizarre plays, you
know, obscure places. But the reality is the Idee
W. does really well on YouTube. And there's a lot
of new interesting metrics about that. So for me,
what I am interested in is challenging the false
notion that these ideas, because you don't see,
you know, whoever interviewed on CNN, that
it means that the idee W is being suppressed,
I don't think is being suppressed anymore
than than me not being on corporate media
as I barely ever m I am being suppressed.
And in any case, the specifics of who
they're voting for in an online poll
I don't find particularly interesting.
And then lastly, elitist populist is asking
whether our caller, Bizerte, are from Columbia,
misspelled here as Columbia, like Columbia
University. Of course, it's the country, Columbia,
whether he is a prank caller. I have to tell you,
I don't know the answer. I don't believe that he
is actually from the country, Columbia. His accent
just doesn't check out. But I don't really know.
I wish I knew more about exactly the origins of
that. But maybe maybe someday we will find out.